[Musique]
donc je commençais mon introduction à
20h avec un exemple si x 30 à son
entreprise
in elle aussi est l'objectif
après laval dans cette entreprise ou
d'une clientèle faire savoir son service
qu'est ce qui fait et on se donne le ton
coeur un tel investissement
au début j'ai parlé lors quand on y va
de façon dispersée
c'est vraiment énorme célébré lors des
grands départs qu'on fait et on se
rendra compte que le résultat final est
pas à la hauteur
métis manquant la finale c'est juste
simplement quelques indices culte et
wana pourquoi parce que on est allé de
façon dispersée en ce moment je voudrais
juste rêver qu'un tout petit train pour
aller des façons de façon assez envie
d'ajouter c'est d'avoir un résultat
efficace en communication la première de
choses pour pouvoir avoir ta efficace
classique ce qui passait là
en communication la première des choses
c'est arrivé à dresser un profil arrivé
à dresser un profil sur l'enquêté
pourquoi ça paraît anodin
peut-être maintenant c'est la chose la
plus importante
quand vous n'avez pas tracer votre
entreprise vous ne saurez pas à qui
s'adresser
vous ne serez pas comment présentez
votre service vous ne saurez pas quand
le présenter et ne sauraient pas comment
le présenter et une façon simple pour
dresser son profil je vous propose la
même scène
ça veut dire que simplement vous même
vous poser la question quel genre de
service d'offres commentait ce que je
peux construire ici service bien sûr il
faudrait pas se poser en cas d'hiver en
écrivant quelque part c'est toujours
important d'écrire quelque part de noter
quelque part vous écrivez quand est-ce
que je peux je peux offrir ses services
à qui jouent à qui j'aurais pu offrir
ses services
c'est important pour moi parce que cela
vous permettra peut-être de ne former
votre
de former l'image de votre vie comme la
surprise je devrais être attractif
attractif salut départ
et de prendre l'exemple
il est parmi les sponsors donc si vous
d'accord fait une promotion dis que j'ai
fait une promotion et la promotion par
grandes villes de sentiments qu'est ce
que ça a coûté à notre devenir la
présence de notre volume donc faudrait
que votre votre rendement de votre
destin votre portrait soit assez
convaincant à cette convaincant pourquoi
vous devez être en mesure d'attirer
l'attention nécessité de susciter
l'intérêt provoquer le désir pour
pouvoir pousser à l'action
et si ces progrès la commande de ces
profils à qui vous permet d'avoir un
petit talent et 20,2 des bars si cet
élément est prêt eh ben le reste va
suivre ça va aller de soi
la deuxième chose que je voudrais la
jolie pour créer une stratégie efficace
est indispensable de savoir pourquoi on
le fait en tout cas si on ne sait pas
pourquoi ça c'est comme prendre une
destination sans sens
prendre une direction sans savoir où on
va c'est vraiment vous allez vous casser
la tête pour rien pourtant mieux
commencer par là alors la neuvième de
choses que je vous propose c'est avoir
un cahier de charges
pourquoi avoir un cahier de charges
c'est vraiment pas un document de 150
pages
ça peut être une page peut-être
s'incline mais c'est important pourquoi
s'arrêtera ce les éléments importants
que vous devez utiliser dans votre
communication
les éléments importants que vous avez
utilisé dans votre stratégie n'est pas
que notre objectif c'est de communiquer
à moins cher ce n'est pas mettre des
nuits
peut-être si j'ai le même camion pour
avant l'ancienne star efficace il
faudrait établir un cahier de charge en
établissement train de changer quelques
lignes qui vous permet de tracer les
grandes lignes de ce que vous pourrez
faire les grandes villes c'est que vos
objectifs
comment est ce que vous pourriez le
faire quand est ce que vous pourriez le
faire encore l'état les ministres écrit
ça vous permet d'évoluer plus vite et
ensuite avoir un planning un planning
est indispensable quoi ça ça vous permet
d'évoluer dans le temps à vous permet
d'évoluer dans le temps ça nous permet
de dire qu'aucun camp ne pas faire et
confère c'est vraiment important d'avoir
ces planètes dans votre stratégie
alors la première de choses que je vous
propose qu'on outils ou avoir communiqué
du classement ne cessant de réseaux
sociaux d'anglais comme paroles réseaux
sociaux tout le monde est d'accord
merci de poser une question à un
entrepreneur aujourd'hui qu'elle aime
réseaux sociaux que vous choisirez pour
votre entreprise au hasard
pardon
qu'est-ce qui fait ok alors
jeudi si vous pensez que vous devez
absolument être présent sur facebook car
c'est le plus populaire de tous les
fronts
fait fausse route chaque réseau sociaux
a deux objectifs spécifiques et les
réseaux sociaux et regroupent une
certaine communauté aussi en fonction
d'un certain âge d'or rencontre quand
vous connaissez votre site si je dis que
je veux m'adresser aux personnes qui ont
par exemple 37 à 45 ans je t'aimerai
savoir quelle est l'orientation qui
regroupe les personnes de cette tranche
d'âge est en ce moment là je me
focaliserai plus sur ce réseau social
que sur les autres d'accord une autre
façon il faut pas dire que comme héros
national
autant je vais partout vous allez vous
casser vraiment 24 est pas le résultat
alors pour bien faire son choix
il faudrait définir sa si une fois que
la cible définie
revient sur le profil une fois que la
sirène est finie une fois que votre
actif sont aussi de nous
ils y croient qu'on si vous avez vos
royal à disposition vous pouvez alors
relancé dans le choix le premier réseau
que je vous propose c'est bien sûr
facebook qui est aujourd'hui la plus
grande plateforme intervenu en terme de
communauté qui réunit déjà pour la
france mène le plus de 30 millions
d'utilisateurs facebook est aussi un
réseau très concurrentiel
ce qui fait de sarah brown très
difficile quand vous lancez je reviens
libre vous lancer et vous faire une
communauté son cours dans l investir un
minimum de la publicité parce que vous
vous rendrez compte facebook elle même
vu aussi de la publicité
alors s'il ya sur votre entreprise
nécessite and successful ya il ya
quelques techniques que je n'ai pas pu
étaler sur place mais vous pouvez passer
par des forums par le forum qui censure
sur facebook qui vous permettant de
partager facilement aussi votre doctrine
mais bien sûr il faudrait savoir qui est
sur facebook d'accord alors nommé 3%
les grandes la majorité de vos clients
et clients et prospects aux attentes
vous pouvez partager des contenus en
images et en vidéos surfer mais les
utilisateurs en moyenne de facebook 18
et 49 feed
il n'y a plus de 93% de postes engageant
sur facebook qui va comporter une image
pour les marques et les camps c'est une
tête ou même vous lisez pas généralement
quand vous volez le texte en tout cas
dans la salle qu'il une lettre seulement
bon qui lit les textes qui sont sur les
images dont vous avez la réponse
c'est clair c'est être vraiment efficace
au fait pour maintenir au texte
choisissez bien 10 37% des utilisateurs
m une page facebook pour participer au
jeu concours
comprenez vous comprenez alors je veux
aller vite fait si je pense je veux
passer là twitter twitter est un réseau
très pudique au lobby alors cette passe
directement avantage
tu t'es dit anthony la plus grande
partie des décideurs comme mon ami
franck si tu as besoin d'être efficace
et avait contacté les meilleures
personnes sont à l'histoire sur twitter
et sur twitter
tous les décideurs qui sont là et
généralement les personnes qui ont aidé
les entreprises qui investissent
beaucoup d'applications développées dans
des entreprises qui travaille dans la
communication parce qu elle donnait les
informations en temps réel
je passe après ça il ya le réseau des
professionnels généralement j'ai
toujours discutable pour le c'est celle
là c'est un réseau professionnel
uniquement professionnelle si vous
voulez vous constituer une bonne base de
données en tant que professionnel et
bien évolué et d'exporter ma tante a
pensé via youtube youtube aussi est un
très bon moteur la chance que je
voudrais plutôt sur lequel je voudrais
insister c'est plutôt le référencement
si vous avez un site internet que le
référencement soit assez facile
d'essayer de mettre de l'accent sur
youtube mettait l'accent sur lui
toujours en attente
la face il s'élance hockey mignon par
instagram et l'âge 1-2 d'yvette et
démentielles focaliser vos sources avant
quand votre événementiel focaliser votre
race date heure du matin ok alors en
rapport avec leurs réseaux sociaux il ya
quelques éléments que je retiens aussi
comme qui sont comme des erreurs
généralement ça veut dire hérité de
barclays description pensant que ça n'a
pas d'importance
évitez de quelques heures qui sont
restés pour être ravi de courir encore
une grande partie qui reste est la
neuvième partie à les sms et les
messageries instantanées
aujourd'hui c'est sa 2e comme la
référence
il ya une entreprise tellement je n'ai
pas vu son expansion
qui aujourd'hui inquiet même un service
de
clients en ligne pourquoi parceque ils
veulent se rapprocher le plus de la
clientèle
alors les sms coûte tinois lessard est
le moyen le plus efficace pour atteindre
votre clientèle parce que vous avez un
retour direct
vous avez un retour direct sur votre
investissement avec expérience
personnalisée ou non personnalisés les
effets sont efficaces à par sms yahia de
quelques avantages avec les sms via la
messagerie instantanée qui permet plutôt
de créer une génération un peu plus
approché avec votre clientèle
et il ya les usages de statut sur les
différentes plateformes en tout cas vous
remarquerez que ça devient très très
fort j'ai remarqué je sais pas si vous
avez manqué de votre côté même youtube
sur ses applications android a ajouté
deux statues cet espace il
l'écran dans l'informatique être à la
page 10 ans de marquer que youtube a
ajouté de statut c'est pour faire
remarquer que c'est quelque chose qui
vaut aussi remarqué que ça attire les
commentaires à l'intérêt en une journée
vous pouvez atteindre 55 cent cinquante
deux ans c'est dans votre carnet d'un
président pas de vous pour avoir incarné
date est assez important alors je veux
conclure avec quelques exemples iman par
exemple vous rendre compte
c'est juste la caméra fait une raison
sur twitter d'après divers en un conte
et combien de comptes truite l ibère a
aussi tapé bénéfique sur tous nos
comptes sont pourtant c'est pas sûr que
ça compte beaucoup pour bnp de cora et
c'était marqué un peu de la concurrence
je passe il ya haddock qui est sûr
reste à g alors je me conclure avec
quelques conseils pratiques jeu du lait
ne soyez pas centré sur vos produits
quand vous présentez données plutôt de
la valeur à votre si votre cible se
sentent intéressés donc qu'il faut de
l'internaute et de vous les présenter
ne soyez pas focus votre produit
n'attendez pas que nous qu'elle fasse
pour le travail
essayez de en plus c'est possible de
travailler en groupe en communauté si
vous avez le moyen intéresser vos amis
ça va toujours y était
autre contenu doit évoluer
une partie de votre cible appréciera
comme autre va partager dans l'autre
parole si une partie est la vidéo pertes
apparemment contre l'autre primera les
images apprennent et aussi à diversifier
ce que nous faisons est aussi conclure
je dirais l'analyse n'oubliez pas dans
l'alluré à la fête et au fait pourquoi
ça me permettra de mettre en valeur ses
qui a marché pour abandonner ce qui n'a
pas marché si vous avez remarqué le raid
sur ses pas être sur twitter focaliser
sur twitter parce que ça m'a surtout des
sommets nous avons ramène pas de clients
mais je crois c'est la phrase qui compte
est bon
si notre stratégie est bien défini le
moyen choisi d'être exploitable pour que
la communication de votre activité soit
efficace je vous remercie
[Applaudissements]